non mais dites là sont pour que soient
totalement tranquille il faut le dire il
faut que vous faut qu'on règle un
dossier pour être totalement sinon il ya
un moment où on va avoir un souci non
avenue
il ya douze moment où va boire
là je pose la question il faut venir
mais vu qu'il faut qu'on règle le
problème si on se pourrir la soirée donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qui confère et que
alc rojo
donc on fait avec et popol nom alors je
ne fête pas comme lui faites pas les
innocents vous savez très bien de qui je
parle
qu'est qu'on fait à 4 shum non mais je
veux dire on applaudit on n'applaudit
pas vous qu'on se mette d'accord parce
que vous êtes d'accord que je dirige
hors de question que j'assume ça tout
seuls de très sain très sympathique je
vous aime beaucoup mais aussi reculé
oui vous dire moi ouattara que quarante
trois ans après les faits je veux pas
réglé le problème comme ça je veux dire
moi à l'époque afin au moment des faits
trois ans je suis à lyon tu penn-ar-pont
en plein stade anal en train d'essayer
de faire entrer car elles ont des rôles
voilà lui hollywood au même stade
on traite pas oui on peut durer est en
train d'essayer de faire qu'il ya rennes
et je devrais me retrouver juge
d'application des peines non je suis
désolé je ne suis pas là greta von baer
du cinéma français anthérieu moi je m'en
fous je n'ai pas de prix bons fous c'est
pour vous qui critiquez qui vous allez
faire ben vous vouliez la démocratie
directe vous en avez un
moi de mon côté je veux dire j'ai tout
réglé moi de mon côté j'ai j'ai décidé
qu'à tchoum n'étaient pas assez grands
pour faire de l'ombre au cinéma français
et au reste de la sélection
c'est pourquoi je vous demande
d'applaudir les dix nominations pour
portrait de la jeune fille en feu de
céline sciamma s'il vous plaît
entre autres
avec avec un casting exclusivement
féminin une équipe technique à majorité
féminine
bravo pour quelqu'un du collectif 55 ans
ce serait sympa de voilà on est plutôt
sur du 80/20 la journée voire à faire
rentrer testostérone les manades suis
dit ça compense parce qu'on a les
misérables avec 11 nominations juste à
côté que des hommes c'est quand même
parce que vous auriez fait un film
ensemble
la gc linon des portraits des misérables
en feu ont coché toutes les cases ont
été pleines argens pour la soirée plus
qu'un nom était inattaquable la ronce
domination aussi pour mon ami nicolas
bedos et la belle époque
[Applaudissements]
alors la vie des formes politiques alors
magnifique c'est une histoire de pitch
très simple c'est l'histoire d'un homme
qui retourne un rassemblement dans le
passé pour pour revivre sa rencontre
avec sa femme alors lui alors il va dans
le passé mais lui reste lui de son âge
mais la fameuse et c'est pas la vraie
c'est lucas 30 ans - quelque chose
scénario mais alors oui attend pas fini
pas de câble le réalisateur de tout ça
pas nicolas le bain le marionnettiste
dans le clip qui ont calé il couche avec
la fiq qui joue la mère mais avec 30 au
moins comme ça et ça permet au pays le
héros de retomber amoureux de sa femme
mais de via la jeune comment ça va cette
analyse nicolas on en est ou non c'est
fini bientôt bon très bien en place et
tu cherche quelqu'un pour pitcher ton
prochain film
alors là tu n'hésites pas on peut me
dire également nos despléchin c'est
cette nomination prouve un libyen
robert müller enfin un film au pitch qui
tient en une phrase qui va être engagé
lucette
heureusement bois alors c'est n'a rien
osé claude amassés par mois non c'était
pour faire un extrait pour ceux qui
n'avaient pas vu non mais c'est un film
qui traite de la misère sociale
d'ailleurs évidemment comme comme chaque
année toute la sélection toute la
sélection des films nommés n'ont pas
peur c'est des films qui n'ont pas peur
de regarder la société en face et de
traiter des grands grands sujets les
grands mots notre société au nom de la
terre qui traite du suicide dans le
monde agricole atlantique lac aux
migrants bien sûr grâce à dieu grâce à
dieu la pédophilie dans l'église
j'accuse la pédophilie dans les années
70 hors norme
l'autisme est le plus grave nous
finirons ensemble la flambée des prix de
l'immobilier au cap ferret bien
[Applaudissements]
pour ouvrir cette cérémonie
je suis très très heureux d'accueillir
une une actrice qui n'a pas eu peur
d'avoir le cancer aussi cette année en
président en acceptant de présider en
tout cas cette cérémonie
mademoiselle sandrine kiberlain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez a pu y arriver